do you prepare your script for video or
you just speak live without preparing
what you say I typically don't script my
videos at all in fact I usually just get
a list of bullet points of things I want
to talk about reading off a script
doesn't feel too authentic to me so I go
off the top of my head a hundred percent
of the time you will never see me
reading off of a script hey what is up
guys in kabhi HD here and recently I
asked you guys on Twitter if you had any
sort of questions about tech or YouTube
or whatever and of course you did there
were plenty of great questions so
without any further ado this is ask
mkbhd episode number 8 let's get right
into it are you switching from the mkh
416 and he has a picture there so I see
you follow me on snapchat yes I am
trying a new microphone I did tease that
on snapchat as new video makers do we
try new equipment we mess around with
different things and this microphone I'm
using now the first video that I shot
with this microphone was the last one
the galaxy s7 review and I feel like it
went pretty well so I haven't even told
you guys what kind of mic it is yet but
I feel like I'll probably reveal that
pretty soon what is the average size of
the final upload file to YouTube also
average time to upload and process this
has changed a bit for me over the years
but my average file upload like the
galaxy s7 review was it's usually
between two gigs and five gigs that
longer video is about four gigs and it
takes me a couple minutes 15 minutes
maybe to upload and then like an hour
and change to process sometimes I get
impatient and I process before it's
fully done in 4k so that's how you get
that 360p Club who's on your playlist at
the moment right now I'm listening to a
lot of logic listening to a lot of older
kanye wolfgang gartner is new album also
I have public profiles on SoundCloud and
Spotify so like you can listen to the
same stuff I listen to is there a cool
person on the planet Ben Neil deGrasse
Tyson it if there is I haven't met them
yet it was awesome to meet Neil deGrasse
Tyson he if you didn't already see this
I tweeted about it already he
interviewed me on his show we just
talked about tech and the future of tech
self-driving cars all kinds of weird AI
stuff like that so I'll link that below
it was really fun and yeah he's
definitely one of the cool
I've ever met and Neil I'd love to
interview you maybe for my youtube thing
maybe we could get in touch about that
what is Android n going to be called my
guess if I was a betting man I'd put
money on Nutella Android n Nutella
there's like two or three other guesses
that may be right but like that's the
far and away favor for me and every time
I see a Google employee tweet any sort
of hint it just reminds me to tell us so
I'm going to go with that do you think
smartphones and tablets are boring is
that why you were branching into
different areas of tech ah the first
part no I don't think they're boring at
all I still think they're awesome
you could argue they're getting stagnant
but I'm branching into other areas of
tech because I'm interested in other
areas of tech and that's the kind of
stuff I wanna make videos about like
cameras for example like you would think
someone who has made hundreds of videos
and put them all on YouTube for people
to critique and watch and see would be
really into cameras and would make
camera videos I am but I've only made
like two or three camera reviews so
that's the kind of stuff like I do want
to branch out and do things other than
smartphones and tablets because it's all
tech this backpack for carrying around
cameras and other gear I don't know if
this is the best one but this is the
backpack that I used and it was in the
galaxy s7 review people are asking about
it what's that red and black backpack
this is a click jetpack 15 I had to go
to amazon.com Ketu get this because it
was out of stock on the u.s. Daum from
Mac mixing definitely convinced me to
get this it's perfect for my gear
meaning it's not too big but it fits
like the camera all the camera
accessories two batteries and lenses and
cards it's perfect and I just take that
and a tripod to the park and go shoot
it's awesome I'll leave a link to that
below the like button I recommend it
have you moved yet okay this is a
question a lot of people have been
asking as you can see I'm still in my
old apartment this is something I've
been working on without getting into too
much detail or finger pointing or
anything weird like that banks banks
don't really understand self-employment
the way that I youtubers do it I don't
know it's hard to explain but yes I'm
still working on that but in the next
like three weeks you're going to see
some pretty dope new spaces I've teased
it exactly one
on Instagram it's coming it's happening
new Tesla are you excited I am very
excited so we're going to get to see the
Tesla Model 3 on March 31st I didn't get
invited to the actual event but I will
definitely be watching it live and we'll
finally get to see what may be like the
make-or-break car for Tesla the $35,000
smaller sedan little brother to the
Model S and I already know Tesla's like
a great company and it's not necessarily
make or break since Tesla is already
doing really well but like this is the
finale this is what they've been working
towards to get electric cars on the map
and then make it available for everyone
this is the car that people want to see
1 plus 3 hype or no hype honestly the 1
plus 3 could Loki be one of the best
phones of this year we're already
looking forward to a couple things like
the new Nexus the new note the new
iPhone but this 1 + 2 was one of the
best phones of last year and a lot of
ways it kind of went under the radar in
that way too but it's a budget phone but
it's built like a tank it's got high-end
specs great performance it's gotten some
updates and it's been ahead of the curve
on a couple things that as USB type-c
has a fingerprint reader so in a lot of
ways this is a great phone it's on mass
drop right now for a much lower price
and you could already get it so it's
still one of the best bang for your buck
phones that you can get it's one of
those rare phones that you can continue
to recommend so I think one plus three
could have a lot of hype going for it
and I'm looking forward to see what that
next phone looks like what are the cons
of using a read other than the size I
would say the cons of using the camera
that I'm using but I like it a lot I
really like this camera but it would be
the battery life here is a battery of
the Canon c100 this battery right here
would last me hours and hours and hours
on end of shooting for multiple videos
this is the battery I throw on the back
of the red and it lasts me a good solid
45 to 55 minutes so there they go what
tech company is innovating the most
right now there's a couple good answers
to this but since I focus a lot on smart
phones I'm going to say LG the LG g5 is
the closest we have to an actual modular
smartphone that's not just cool for the
sake of being modular but it's actually
legitimately awesome idea I hope to get
my hands on that phone pretty soon we're
getting a little more info about how
much the modules themselves the friends
will call
now hopefully have a video about that
phone in the next couple weeks to show
you guys I want to see what this phone
is all about and hopefully it lives up
to the hype that a modular phone does so
you have it thank you guys everyone who
is asking questions and if you have any
other questions maybe that didn't get
answered feel free to ask them in the
comment section below this is one of
those videos where I'll hang out a lot
in the comments section and try to
answer a bunch of questions that's
basically been it thank you for watching
and I'll talk to you guys the next one
peace